make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I just saw the trailer for
spider-man far from home the official
trailer cuz I don't even notice it like
I was I jumped onto a video what was it
the the video about the expert in the
Fantastic Four and I was looking at the
comments right because like I'll peruse
through the comments and and people were
just like the new spider-man trailer
confirms the multiverse and I'm like
what what do you mean like one there's a
new spider-man trailer and two
multiverse and so on so I jump on to
YouTube right now I'm just like screw
the comments so I jump onto YouTube and
I'm just like spider-man far from home
trailer because it's really all you have
to search for it and and they like sure
enough that's like an hour ago the
trailer dropped yeah I'm looking at that
they're like it's Mysterio but it's
Mysterio from a different universe like
the events of in-game tore a hole in the
multi or tore hole in our universe and
basically access the multiverse and I
was like oh my god
most Universal Avengers okay so here's
the thing here's the that's the first
thing I thought like the first thing
that came to mind The Ultimates
multiversal Avengers and I was like oh
my god this is gonna be Sophie so here's
the thing here's the thing
alright I have no doubt the movie itself
will focus almost exclusively on
spider-man and the supporting cast right
like I doubt they'll bring the ultimate
in because a really cool way is to kind
of have Spider Man basically face off
against Mysterio but it makes sense that
this basically concludes the entire
phase of Age 3 and then it basically
ends with like the multiverse is out
there and who the hell knows what's
going to come out of it but the idea of
the multiversal Avengers that excites
the heck out of me and here's the reason
why the multiversal Avengers are a
relatively new team right so like
originally they were they were created
by sunspot by Robert DeCosta so the way
that's played out you had Hickman's
defenders and New Avengers yes I always
referenced that you guys have no clue
how many things came out of Avengers and
new avengers by Jonathan Hickman like
literally everything Marvel's published
since 2015 has been based on Hickman's
Avengers of New Avengers run right like
this like so much stuff is based on that
but the idea here was that when the
collapse of the multiverse was happening
that what they needed was an Avengers
team to conditionally go out and explore
the multiverse and find out what caused
it right so basically you had you had
night masks who could teleport across
almost any space in time you had a star
brand who had unlimited power but his
power was relative to whoever he was
fighting right so he would only have as
much power as he needed to defeat
whatever photo he's facing it wasn't
like he could access on
our or whatever you had Thor you had
Hyperion and then you had ex nihilo and
an abyss that's who it was and there was
a multiversal Avengers they go into the
multiverse this dude it's like the
coolest thing ever it's dude the last
ride of Thorin Hyperion you're just it's
dude it's like the most beastly thing
ever because like Hyperion shows up in
hit like Marcus Milton show them he's
like earth one three zero three four he
shows up from that alternate universe
and like he's just kind of like this
Boise guy he's like Superman right like
he's like well you know we're gonna do
the right thing guys and you know I
always do the right thing and I never do
the wrong thing and you know I never
drink alcohol or anything like that like
I just you know I take my vitamins and
just and just by golly we can win you
know and it's just like it's very
Superman esque right well didn't like by
the end of hitman's Avengers and New
Avengers he's just like give me some of
that Mead Thor but it's like he's
battle-hardened right like like he's
like I've seen some things like he's
battle-hardened whatever and so there's
like this really cool woman where
there's like a rift in space rhyme like
a rift in this they they they get to
this other this alternate universe where
there's nothing in there there's no life
or anything there's nothing in there
except for like this rift in space and
the end up finding out that's the back
door the beyonders we're using to get
into the multiverse and kill all the
cosmic entities and so when they arrive
there they're just like okay
so this is really all this here and like
beyonders start coming out and basically
like Star brandeis night mask dies um
you end up having like ex nihilo and an
abyss who died and essentially all this
left is like Thorin Hyperion and so like
like the beyonders like there's there's
a couple beyonders there and like Thorne
Hyperion are talking to each other and
my parents like we're gonna die here
today and Thor is like yeah man but if
we're gonna die let's go out with a bang
and so like so and so Hyperion is
syberius is something on the lines of of
like brother I will see you in Valhalla
and Thor's like today brother I won't
race you there and they go racing and
like at this rift and like all these
beyonders come pouring out and it's like
this amazing last stand and like like it
just starts to like kind of zoom out and
then like hitman writes it out and he
was like he was like in the Bleak cold
dead of space - gods fought against many
there was it there was there was like a
crack of thunder something else and then
silence and it's just like damn that's
how Thor Hyperion go out against like
it's like like hopeless odds there's no
way they could win but they go gets like
hopeless odds and like they die and it's
just like dude that was the most
last thing I've ever seen yeah that's
like my favorite part of the whole story
that him and the part where like Doctor
Doom shows up right because like they're
they're hunting for like removal all the
guy who started it all and then it turns
out to be dr. doom and it's like I knew
it I knew is gonna be dr. doom it's
always dr. doom pulling the strings but
but nonetheless so so really cool
concept
the multiversal videos were awesome
right like that's what they were
supposed to end then you pick up its
all-new all-different marvel and so
algae ewing launches a book called The
Ultimates do The Ultimates were cool
it was the Ultimate Avengers for
ultimate problems and basically you have
Adam Brashear blue Marvel thank God
Marvel finally did something with him
then they canceled the comic and so now
who the hell knows what he's even doing
now well you've got Adam Brashear blue
Marvel who's like this super powerful
guy who's also like a super genius
you've got a black panther you have you
have Monica Rambeau you've got God who
else do you have
you got anti man Connor Sims but here's
the show of until I the second a third
story arc and then he becomes a new
Herald of Galactus um and then you've
got Carol Danvers Captain Marvel and
you've got a couple other people but
it's basically like the heavy hitters
right like [ __ ] these are some powerful
people and like if they if they if they
come in man look here's the thing if
they come looking for you it's curtains
but basically it was an Avengers team
that would traverse the multiverse that
would go into the multi oh it was
America Chaves to you but it was it was
a it was an Avengers team that would go
into the multiverse and then serve the
purpose of like tracking down and like
solving problems with different things
like that sometimes it would fight
sometimes they wouldn't but the basic
story was that like somebody had chained
up eternity right so basically they end
up having to fight against like the
first universe and like a whole army of
like Celestials and aspirants and stuff
like that like super cosmic beings just
so it's like one of the coolest stories
if you never read al viewings Ultimates
you need to like you really really need
to it's it's one of the coolest stories
ever honestly it's less than 20 issues
like it's not even that long like Marvel
cancelled it really fast and it was
because they never really marketed it to
anybody
I think they never really said like hey
everyone everybody go read this it was
just like the stories there and it got
blended in with like the 50 other comics
they were publishing every two weeks and
it was it was it was kind of ridiculous
but nonetheless the idea of spider-man
far from home by revealing the ultimate
versus basically says like almost
anything is possible and and like
creating a multiversal Avengers team we
be legit like like and it doesn't really
have to be like a multiversal Avengers
team per se like in terms of heavy
hitters they can just be the Secret
Avengers right like just create a Secret
Avengers team that's a black ops
surgical unit and they just go in like
it's just like a wet work team right
okay Secret Avengers back in in 2010
Marvel had something called the heroic
age why does that matter because in the
year 2000 Brian Michael Bendis came on
board a handful of people came on board
but so did Joe Cassano and Joe casabas
idea as editor-in-chief was wipe the
slate clean redo it all right so like a
whole bunch of things came out of that
the x-men were basically like like they
were there a number we reduced down like
198 you probably heard of the story
house of him that was that that was that
was what they did in order to reduce the
number down The Avengers were
disassembled during the Avengers
disassembled story arc and the New
Avengers were created in their place the
marriage between spider-man of Peter and
I'm sorry spider-man and Mary Jane
Watson was removed during the events of
one more day where spider-man fans still
can't get over like it's like a lot of
changes came out of that so fast forward
maybe like 7 1 in 7 years maybe like
eight years right so let's you doesn't 8
2009 Marvel had a line of comics called
Dark Reign now and Marvel Comics will
usually have our events right Infinity
Gauntlet infinity War Secret Invasion
well you have events that run for like a
set amount of time six months to a year
depending on how long the events gonna
be and how how far back publishing gets
pushed or you know whether there's
delays or different things like that but
say you go for like a seamless release
of a 12 issue story or released once
every month it's a year-long event
that's usually how all that works and
then all the things are tie-ins under
that right so right now you have war of
realms which is where the Dark Elves and
all that kind of stuff from Sparta high
are invading the invading like earth and
the main Marvel Universe and like all
those characters are basically like
getting decimated
more or less right so what do you have
her like tie-ins for that Dark Reign was
not like that it was a rebranded so what
you had were like the Dark Avengers the
dark x-men like all that kind of stuff
uh you had like Dark Reign Fantastic
Four there wasn't really a dark
Fantastic Four
but at the time Norman Osborn was
running shield and so the result was
that uh Norman Osborn destroyed shield
Reve and rebranded it recreated it and
called it hammer eventually he was
defeated and then Captain America would
replaced replace Norman Osborn and then
he in turn recreated shield when he did
he created like these little small
versions of the Avengers in the form of
like this like these all these old
teams one of them was called The Secret
Avengers and the purpose of The Secret
Avengers was to go through and undo
everything Norman Osborn did during Dark
Reign and so you have like like people
who serve different purposes right like
beast was a scientist and black widow
and and Moon Knight were like the the
Black Ops guys because they did some
black up stuff in the past and things
like that but it was basically like
different like it was it was targeted
and different characters serve different
purposes but they were all part of a
cohesive unit but unless I mean it's you
know I kind of digress here the overall
gist of this is that a lot of things can
come out of smart as the spider-man far
from home trailer now what you basically
have here the spider-man far from home
movie this is the final movie of face of
phase 3 this really kind of wraps it all
up and it leaves it open-ended and says
now we've got access to the multiverse
and who in the heck knows what's gonna
come through you know what it reminds me
of it reminds me of war of kings and
Thanos imperative is what it reminds me
of all you guys ever read that story so
what you had you had a story called war
of kings rights like Black Bolt in the
Inhumans take over the the Kree Empire
it doesn't really matter because a Kree
suck and then you have Vulcan who's the
third summer's brother who can control
all forms of like exotic energy right
like there's one point where Cyclops
shoots his optic beam at Vulcan and
Vulcan sticks his hand out and the beam
goes like around him and back at Cyclops
and it's just kind of like so that's
badass but like anyway he ends up taking
over the Shiar empire and the two
empires go to war when they do like the
battle is so extreme it rips a hole in
the fabric of the universe and opens up
for the cancerverse this universe where
no one can die they come pouring through
so instead of the Avengers you have the
revenger basically everybody's evil
right like evil Avengers is more or less
what it is it was a cool little story
arc but it reminds me of that and like
Stannis imperative was the cancerverse
storyline where like well all that stuff
happened where they came pouring out and
all those different things in like they
have like the Galactus engine where
Galactus is just like this giant machine
thing they use you know and like like
it's just like it just kills everything
it comes across like all this designed
to do is just like harness the power
cosmic and just wipe everything out like
it's it's crazy
in terms of all the power that it has
but it was a cool concept and and like
it reminds me a lot of that right like
tearing a hole in the fabric of the
universe and and you know what can come
out of it but this opens the door like
like you guys have no clue I could go on
and on and on and on and on and on in
terms of what they can do like the
possibilities are endless
right like I mean opening the door for
the multiverse there's anything that
you can do anything they want you might
I think you bring back a man if they
wanted to they probably want they could
bring back like classic Thor they
probably want they could give us a like
a version that's like the ultimate for
basically where you spent like the Power
Suit and like the power hammer and all
that kind of stuff we probably won't see
that oh but we can get all those things
right like they do for the door for like
the x-men that come in from an alternate
universe the Fantastic Four to come in
from an alternate universe it would make
sense with the Fantastic Four because
they explore things Galactus could show
if we're gonna alternate universe right
like we're seeing that play out right
now and Doctor Strange like the lattice
was sent for the main Marvel Universe to
like an alternate dimension where you
have like my nightmare and all those
different things and Galactus is just
like consuming everything and almost
nobody can stop them like Galactus
versus Dormammu that story is legit like
it's it's there's a lot of things going
on right now in Marvel Comics that we
could see play out in the in the film so
like it's cool and and there are so many
things that come at like they're there
there is so much potential on what they
could do so here's a thing the way in
game ended I was kind of like okay so I
don't really know if they're gonna be
able to do a whole lot after this they
kind of work themselves into a corner
for the casual moviegoers here's the
list of things that we have not seen and
this is just off the top of my head
right okay so we have not seen acts of
vengeance when Loki grabs all the earths
all the earth supervillains and faces
them off against the superheroes we have
not seen like fatal attractions where
bang you know basically wages war on the
world and then ritzy adamantium out of
Wolverine's skeleton we have not seen
strife the future evil counterpart of
cable who basically came back to the
present day and held off a full
contingent of the x-men the Avengers and
the end x-factor at the same time by
himself we haven't seen like X I should
work table bases we did the same thing
we have not seen the onslaught saga
where werewolf arranged for us I'm sorry
Xavier is frustration with humanity
merges with Magneto's hatred for
humanity and like creates the super
powerful being that basically nobody can
stop except for the Incredible Hulk and
only because whoo I'm sorry Jean Grey
grabs the mind of Bruce Banner rips it
out and then in turn sounds like The
Incredible Hulk is just unbridled
savagery power and punches a hole in
ocelots armor and all the characters who
weren't selling basically weren't
selling comics jumped inside of
onslaught and then dissipated it we
haven't seen the villain apocalypse we
haven't seen mr. sinister we haven't
seen any of the x-men we haven't seen
any of the fan
for we have not seen the Council of
reeds where you end up discovering
there's this great big huge council of
Reed Richards which exists in this like
Nexus where there's like every version
of reed that could ever exist we have
not seen the war of the four cities we
have not seen Franklin Richards we
haven't seen valaria do the valaria
Richards we haven't seen Doctor Doom we
have not seen protege we haven't seen
firestorm we haven't seen Captain
Britain we haven't seen Excalibur we
haven't seen Alpha Flight we haven't
seen any anything with like South
America and like sunspot and all those
guys we have not seen anything relating
to like what is it the what's the name
of that Japanese team they may have busy
made a movie off of it but like it's not
the actual Japanese I can't what the
name of that thing is anyway uh we have
not seen mangog who's like the one being
that Odin is afraid let me tell you
something in the comics when ant would
like when Magog shows up and decides he
wants to storm Asgard Odin pisses his
pants he's like that guy is legit he's
he's powered by hatred man and it's like
the one thing like no one can defeat oh
no dude chaos king we haven't seen
Hitler chaos King let me tell you
something man I'm not SEMA Kobashi
who's this guy invade it and just killed
like almost every god he came across and
he's just like a fraction of the power
of oblivion the cosmic entity who we
have not seen we have not seen mistress
death we haven't seen an eternity we
haven't seen infinity we haven't seen
Galactus we haven't seen protege we
haven't seen um God we haven't seen Moon
Knight we haven't seen maximum security
we've not seen operation galactic storm
we haven't we have there's so many
things that we have not seen yet that we
can see later on down the line what a
time to be a comic book fan we are not
prepared dude there are so many things
that are gonna get this it's gonna be
nuts there's so many things are gonna
come out and that's just that's just off
top my head like we haven't seen any of
these stories right we haven't seen any
of these things yet and like it's crazy
what all there is to see like is it's
it's dude it's it's the possibilities
are limitless right like they're
basically limitless it's bananas like
it's it's bonkers but would that be said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace